cosa devo fare il video per fare un
video clan video di Sam Bella a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono Favij e oggi sono con alcuni lo
conosceranno altri no ve lo presento mio
padre Allora ragazzi bisogna fare una
cosa importante io non ho mai fatto
questa cosa con voi l'ho fatta una volta
sola ma non così bene che è una sorta di
quiz sai tipo quelli che fate voi su
Facebook che insalata sì quello l'hanno
fatto su di me risponderei alle domande
con il mio letto top perché adesso te lo
passo le guardiamo insieme Ovviamente
però ehm non ti dirò assolutamente nulla
dovrei rispondere con le tue forze come
puoi notare un letto della Madonna con
uno schermo ampio e una 3080 ti hai un
gpo invidia 3080 ti ha all'interno e con
processore Intel Core fino a i9 e
soprattutto stasera RGB Seul Series
telecamere no telecamera hai rotto il
cazzo
Vorrei tenere questi si può tenere
Secondo te Quale di questi film ha
recitato Favij dai gameteo the game
Gamer interpretato
sì
dove vado avanti ma non ho capito Quale
di questi Gameplay non è mai stato fatto
da Favij
Surgeon Simulator
No ho sbagliato
sul secondo canale Come si chiamava il
suo primo canale YouTube Gamer YouTube
Gamer Baby Gamer shared gaming
dorigamer95
Bravo bravo
quale programma televisivo ha
partecipato a Favij i social House
Pechino Express socialface Avanti un
altro Social Face Beh 4 su 5 finito
finito finito Complimenti Sei un vero
fanne e se Favij vedesse il tuo
risultato sarebbe orgoglioso di te Sono
orgoglioso di te quindi effettivamente è
vero è vero In che anno è nato Favij Non
lo so io papà 95
Dove è nato Favij all'ospedale Torino
Ecco in che anno ha aperto il suo Canale
Eccolo perché oggi stiamo registrando
oggi questo video Oggi ho fatto oggi ho
fatto 10 anni probabilmente stiamo
registrando questo video solo per quello
In che anno ha raggiunto Il Milione di
iscritti questo è onnivoro un milione di
iscritti Secondo me nel 2015
[Musica]
molto standard Oh questo mi sembra un
po' più strutturato Proviamo questo
allora incanannato l'abbiamo 10 domande
vai Quando il gioco non ha mai fatto
altro Angri Mario secondo
me andremo
televisivo socialface Eccolo parmigiano
ho detto 14 adesso dico 215 o prima ho
detto 14 adesso dico io una donna che
brutta Essere vecchi me la rischia No
vabbè Queste erano solo domande che
avevamo già fatto andiamo avanti questo
non è un quiz Ma in che Favij ti
identifichi Quindi alla fine ti esce un
Favij diverso partiamo prima
sì che cacchio no dai dai leggi qua se
io ho 8 q
poi
una bella bandiera che paese è non sono
sfigate visto santo Dio
Cristo Santo Iddio
siete uscito Favij ha luci blu sei
attrattivo e probabilmente sei anche
bastardo a volte risulta anche stupido
grazie a C'è un sito chiamato youtubers
italiani.it se sei arrivato in questa
pagina è molto probabile che sei uno
youtuber
veggente lo faccio io perché mi sa che
non lo sono io Quali sono i primi tre
livelli che un canale YouTube deve
superare prima di prendere gli ambiti
trofei Play button legno Ferro bronzo
grafite o quale o bronzo o piombo ferro
e rame perché adesso quando tu crei un
canale YouTube devi superare questi tre
livelli prima del Play button legno
ferro e bronzo Non lo so quali sono i
requisiti che un canale deve avere per
avere per attivare la partnership con
YouTube non so neanche questo non nego I
like sicuramente Secondo me 1000
iscritti e 4.000 ore di Wash Time che
non hanno scritto Watch time a quanti
iscritti si vince il Trofeo Silver
Creator Awards
a quanti iscritti si sblocca il
community Tab
perché sta decollando il bagno a quanti
iscritti si sblocca la stazione
merchandising Veramente io di YouTube
non so un cazzo Cosa sono gli shorts dei
Graziosi calzoncini fin là Bravo mamma
avessi risposto Questo è uno shorts eh
calzoncini video verticali più brevi di
un minuto video più brevi di mezzo
minuto per la mamma sono calzoncini
video più brevi di mezzo minuto no più
breve verticali
che non sono ragazzi Dove si trova la
stazione Analytics di un canale YouTube
nella sua homepage nella sezione
commenti in YouTube studio YouTube su
Brown
tra studiare quanto tempo ci vorrebbe
per guardare tutti i video su YouTube ci
voleva almeno 3 secoli ti dovrebbero
58.000 anni ci vorrebbero sette anni a
velocità doppia termine
58.000 anni secondo me A cosa servono
gli hashtag ad aumentare la visibilità
sostenitrice di ricerca generale un
effetto cascata che porta la
viralizzazione 30 minuti ad aumentare la
velocità di lievitazione Io credo che
vengano catalogati in pagina apposite no
parlamentare No forse hai ragione tu sai
metto il tuo che informazioni Usa
YouTube Perché catalogare i video titolo
descrizione tag e sottotitoli
sottotitoli miniatura tag
#invia vediamo che abbiamo fatto Sei
risposte giuste su 10 uno schifo ed è il
mio lavoro ragazzi Allora innanzitutto
non erano i primi tre livelli non erano
legno ferro e bronzo Ma erano grafiche
opale e bronzo poi è fantastico
requisiti devo azzeccati gli scritti per
il Silver credo le vostre carte quanti
iscritti si sblocca come ti Dab lo
sbaglierò ve l'ho detto 500 a quanti
iscritti si sblocca il merchandising ho
sbagliato pure questo Cosa sono gli
shorts cioè aveva ragione mamma erano i
calzoncini A cosa servono gli hashtag e
anche quello l'ho sbagliato comunque
Grazie di aver visto questo video
ringraziamo papà per aver partecipato a
questo video e mamma per aver fatto da
voice over
e Sam per avere dormito quindi ragazzi
Spero che il video vi sia piaciuto come
se vi è piaciuto lasciate un commento e
un mi piace Grazie ancora Grazie papà e
Sandro per la partecipazione ci vediamo
ad un prossimo video tirato fuori allora
ha portato lui adesso lo usa Lui non so
se ve lo ricordate Beh ragazzi